on va voir votre data potato 24 ne cache
pas que j'étais sur l'émission de
castaldi j'ai pas pu bosser ce passage
la tête avec william ça faisait cinq
mois que vous discutiez avec lui sur les
réseaux sociaux
vous êtes donc rencontré pour la
première fois ça va kane a lâché ce que
le rendez vous était assez gênant vous
n'aviez pas grand chose à vous dire mais
c'est vrai que voilà on sentait qu'il y
avait un feeling quand même quelque
chose qui se passe regarde il exactement
comme comme vous l'imaginez est pareil
je pourrais tu es mieux
ouais et mais tu manges arrivée ouk
puissantes agissant et son super bourrin
[Musique]
donc m après ouais après à savoir
comment ça va se passer par la suite on
verra
[Musique]
non c'est génial de vente
je ne sais pas déçu quand vous l'avez
non pas du tout il était comme vous
l'imaginez aliou sow directeur anta diop
ils ont pas te montrer ça s'est pas
vraiment passé comme ça c'est à dire
alors en fait bon ou avant de avant de
rentrer sur le tournage on est confiné à
l'hôtel
du coup dans des hôtels différents mais
chez les garçons et du coup on s'appelle
tous les soirs en face time et on se met
d'accord sur l arrivée pas de bisous
bisous direct et aura et je sais pas
pourquoi monsieur s'est décidée au
dernier au moins de m'embrasser
directement bas on regarde pas que ça en
fait il m'a fait une vraie galoche et du
coup je les pousse et n'ont pas montré
ils vont couper à d'accord il ya eu
gateway c'était vraiment gênant et du
coup je me suis rendu compte de mon
geste et je vais faire un petit bisou
d'accord je vois le bénir ouais alors
malgré des débuts compliqués la
rencontre a continué dans les meilleurs
conditions puisque vous avez accepté de
poursuivre cette rencontre dans la
chambre et le feeling la c1 parole c'est
encore un autre
non non je suis en train de me dire et
puis on kiffe pas il trouve
je alors que moi je suis amoureuse
il faut que ça le fasse alors
je suis contente de fou
son regard en dit long et le mur aussi
je pense très très bien parti il a un
peu tout ce que je recherche
et ça ça fait du bien après leur nuit au
château
kahina et william n'ont pas réussi à
passer du coup de foudre à une relation
sérieuse
je me suis vite rendu compte que c'était
pas quelqu'un pour moi et
kahina elle était donc il doit aussi on
se rencontrer et c'est vrai que vous
avez vu williams je crois qu'il ya eu il
ya eu çà c'est ça c'est fait ça c'est
fait des coulisses c'est à dire il ya eu
le bas si vous êtes sortiront sur n'a
pas nommément mis d'accord très bien là
excusez la crise est là et dont vous
êtes resté combien de temps ensemble
ensuite deux jours deux jours à 8 mois
et après pourquoi ça c'est pas vous
voulez rester avec lui vous étiez
amoureuse
non non non mais en fait on entend dire
je suis amoureuse mais la phrase n'est
pas vraiment donc c'est pas vous avez
vous une très beaux édifices non en fait
la vraie phrase je peux pas dire que je
suis encore amoureuse dans et
malheureusement on entend dire je suis
amoureuse ah ouais bah ouais le montage
j'ai pas compris
ah oui c'est oui c'est vrai mais anigo
les six mois et est donc voilà vous avez
c'était une petite aventure mais c'était
vjepa construire quelque chose avec
non en fait il ya eu un gros coup de
coeur sur les réseaux sociaux il ya eu
un gros coup de coeur lors de la
rencontre mais malheureusement
virtuel et le réel c'est non ça n'a pas
fait avant tout pratique est alors une
physique n'a pas eu ce truc et je suis
resté trois ans avec une meuf de
bordeaux oui eh ouais ouais
comment on faisait pour le train avait
là toujours à distance n'a pas aboli la
passion ça va bien je vais vous dire
quand on aime les kilomètres ne sont
donc pas que ta gueule tagada mais
c'était un ch'ti ya des styles père
longtemps voilà non mais est donc ouais
vous voyez pas avec lui non pas du tout
pas du tout là aujourd'hui vous êtes en
couple
non du tout vous êtes célibataire et
vous voulez pas reprendre avec williams
non non pas du tout d'accord j'avais les
jambes aux de faire cette émission
ouais franchement c'était une belle
équipe aussi vraiment trouvé l'amour
voilà dans les sillons se rencontrer
ouais
williams avait rien vous y croyez en
fait non ouais j'y croyais en fait non
d'aquarelles vous êtes heureuse quand
même aujourd'hui
bien sûr pour chercher quoi l'amour avec
un grand a
avner taille est comme toujours actuelle
vous avez décidé de changer de méthode
je pense qu'il ya un fait si tu as bien
tant mieux mais ça va aller chercher
c'est ce qu'on dit toutes les femmes de
moi je m'appelle
kahina en tout cas merci vous pouvez
nous dire d'autre voilà sur cette
aventure c'est le montage qui vous un
peu déçu ou penser que non le montage
était très bien après voilà c'est le jeu
c'est le jeu c'est de la télé vous
n'êtes pas voir voilà continuer
l'aventuré williams et faire une belle
et jeune bannissement ne change pas
drômois koch pas déçu j'étais déçu sur
le sur le coup comme ça quand ça n'a pas
collé bonjour mais non j'ai vécu une
très belle expérience la production
génial moi qui ai fait une autre télé ça
n'a rien à voir
j'ai été prétendantes dans ma chambre la
séduction de quoi non je suis vous plaît
donc on rêve villa d'écart brisé vous
avez toujours le coeur brisé vous
j'espère que vous allez trouver l'amour
non merci